the first trailer for Sony's Morbius
does an excellent job setting up the
core story of the film a doctor
transforms into a vampire after
attempting to cure his rare blood
disease but it also features subtler
moments that offer significance these
are the small details you missed in the
Morbius trailer the first 45 seconds or
so of the Morbius trailer establish that
the doctor is suffering greatly because
of his illness he's shown with wires
tape to his head and neck struggling to
walk with forearm crutches and hunched
over a bed as a fellow doctor
meticulously counts of vertebrae of his
spine protruding from a skin in a
voiceover he says I'm running out of
time it soon becomes clear that dr.
Morbius intends to cure his blood
disease using non traditional medicine
and his own devices which raises a red
flag to the woman working alongside him
when Morbius Azer what he's discovered
would be a cure she asks at what cost
this line is more than just the musings
of a concerned colleague is
foreshadowing of the highest degree the
woman who speaks it as Martine Bancroft
Morbius is fiancee played by Adria
aronia throughout the Marvel Comics
Martine actually dies several times is
resurrected and eventually becomes a
living vampire herself it's unclear at
this point in time however whether the
Morbius film will depict the death
subsequent revival and transformation of
Martine while several members of the
Mobius Castro announced far before the
release of this first trailer one actors
involvement in the film came as a
complete surprise and was only revealed
through the new footage at the very end
of the mobius trailer Michael Keaton
appears as Fulcher aka Adrian Toomes the
villain of spider-man homecoming those
who stuck around for the spider-man
homecoming post-credit scenes might
recognize what the salvager / arms
trafficker is wearing in the mobius
trailer as a hooded Morbius approaches
as white van vulture has shown donning
the same prison jumpsuit he was wearing
in homecomings mid-credits stinger but
in the scorpion pun anyway since its
appearance the Morbius trailer is so
brief there's no way to tell when
exactly the meeting between vulture and
Morbius takes place in the movies
timeline because of that it's also not
clear how significant Keaton's role in
the film will be that doesn't mean
Keaton's appearance has all for showing
shock though the vultures brief end of
Tralee reveal
might allude to the early foundations
for a potential sinister six team up on
the silver screen
well the spider-man villain team has had
numerous iterations and the comics
several of its key or occurring paddies
including venom Mysterio Doctor Octopus
and Green Goblin have already appeared
in both Sony's Spidey offerings and that
shared MCU installments well nothing has
been confirmed Keaton's surprised cameo
in Morbius is much larger than the
return of a famous face it could signal
a more connected and expanding web of
the Spidey universe with Sony launching
and planning to launch so many
spider-verse movies it's hard to keep up
with who and what we can expect to see
out of the growing web of adaptations
one image captured within the Morbius
trailer helps further that confusion or
air of mystery depending on whom you ask
in the first look footage in a blink in
your missing moments
Morbius walks past a mural of spider-man
with the word murderer spray-painted
across it there are a couple of things
to pull apart from the moment the first
being Spidey's Alfred it appears to be a
blend of several spider-man suits but
looks most similar to some Raimi's
version if you can remember all the way
back to the 2000s Tobey Maguire embodied
the webslinger when Raimi spider-man
trilogy was dominating silver screens if
you were a hardcore fan of those films
you may have also bought the PlayStation
4 exclusive spider-man game featuring an
animated version of Peter Parker wearing
a Raimi like suit which is seemingly the
same suit shown in the mural that
appears in the Morbius trailer the
second noticeable thing is the actual
language covering the image the
murderous statement points to Tom
Hollands most recent turn as Peter
Parker in spider-man far from home
during the final scenes of that film
Peter is accused of killing Mysterio
using footage the villain doctored and
sent to JJ Jameson who broadcasted it in
a video posted to the Daily Bugle net
there's no clarity about what this
moment and the mobius trailer could mean
just yet but here's the hoping or the
jet Spidey cameo happens in the
theatrical cut later on in the trailer
there's a shot of Matt Smith's character
walking cautiously through a seemingly
abandoned subway station in the film
Smith doesn't play some random
tie-wearing dude who likes to walk
around alone at night
he plays Lucius crown Smith's locust
crown is said to be the central
antagonist of Morbius however Smith's
character has been described as quote
Morbius his best friend so what's going
on here in the Marvel Comics crown is
best known as Hunger another vampire
whose origin is unknown and who has
nothing to do directly with the events
that lead to Morbius transforming into a
pseudo vampire but there's also the
character of Emil Niko's dr. Morbius is
closest friend and lab associate who
died as a result of Morbius his post
transformation confusion and bloodlust
only to be made into a vampire by
another unrelated comic character later
since Smith's character as crown as a
last name it's been as soon from the
get-go that he's partially inspired by
the pre-existing Marvel antagonist and
the rest of his characterization is
filled in by the general concept of Emil
Niko's Smith's character will reportedly
be afflicted by the same blood disease
Morbius which is the basis of their
friendship and perhaps his ultimate
destruction once Morbius kinda-sorta
cures and curses himself the mobius
trailer also gives us a good look at
Tyrese Gibson scare achter whom we know
from one of the actors Instagram posts
at the FBI agent Simon Stroud in the
pages of Marvel Comics Stroud is an
agent of shield term mercenary who seems
to always find himself tangled up with
the weird a Denison's of the marvel
universe including Morbius Stroud is
sporting some interesting tech in his
brief appearance in the mobius trailer
he's seen wearing a sleeve that appears
to offer augmentation for his right arm
and specifically his hand
Stroud was never depicted as having any
kind of enhancements in the comics and
this one raises an interesting question
who built the thing shroud off and
worked side by side with Morbius in the
comics and this tech looks like the kind
of thing that the good doctor with his
Nobel prize-winning expertise in
physiology and medicine might have
constructed obviously Stroud won't be
depicted as a SHIELD agent in this film
as the sonne universe of Marvel
characters and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as
ostensibly separate for now still
Strauss dapper attire and the fact that
he's seen backed by a number of cops
seems to indicate that he'll be in some
kind of position of authority meeting
that Morbius may very well have a friend
in high places to help and stick him
from tricky situations check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]